coming to you from New York City this
week and every week it's the been Kissel
show alright welcome to the show
everyone I am Ben Kissel as always
joined by Mike Koz Carelli thanks for
being here Mike thank you alright
today's guests we're honored to have him
you can see him he's playing the younger
mad off in the television miniseries mad
off
he's also he is also an editor for
Mother Jones Ben Dreyfus is with us
thanks for having me thanks for being
here Ben Dreyfus I we had a question I
had a question before the show began how
do you pronounce Bernie's last name when
I say Bernie of course I'm referring to
Madoff or mad off it turns out it is
made off like made off with the money
okay the only reason I know that is
because it looks like it should be mad
off right and I said mad off a number of
times on the takes and it was around
take five where some producer ran in and
was like can't Waze been saying he's
been saying and they came and said it's
Madoff like made on and of course you're
playing younger Madoff so you should own
know your own last name but the thing is
when you're reading the script you don't
think that you're often gonna be saying
your own name that much because you're
not you're not thinking that you're
gonna be going oh I'll just be repeating
my name over and over write things out
you do when you're trying to sell people
stocks you say your name oh is that
right I had no idea this was the 50s it
was before things were different so as
you were playing the younger Madoff
character did you learn how to swindle
people I already knew how to what's the
number one thing you got to know for all
the young swindlers out there or the
aspiring swindlers what's the number one
thing they got to know just lie just
like comfortable lying take some beta
blockers you won't sweat your hands will
be calm sly and make people feel
comfortable you want to buy a boat I got
a great boat for you Wow need to have a
boat you can just find the I totally
believed you and that's exactly what Ted
Bundy used to do as well he would always
say want to help me with my boat and
meanwhile he's in landlocked he's in
landlocked Seattle or something like
that they're like of course you got a
boat here in the middle of this Walmart
parking lot why wouldn't you mr. Bundy
you're attractive want to kill and
consume young men and boys Ted Bundy is
definitely the person who knows how to
do it absolutely I saw on Twitter you
were mentioned
for your father richard dreyfuss of
course of mr. Holland's Opus Fame the
greatest role in the history of
Hollywood mr. Holland of course you were
saying that this is the first role where
you were really proud of your father
because the character himself madoff had
so much depth I wouldn't say it's like
the first ever but no but in a little
while that's like 10 years yeah my dad's
had a had a span of like it's been it's
been a while since he's had like a part
that he could dive into as well and it
gives him as much to do as he has in
this one right because you know now he's
old and when you're old and Hollywood
you're relegated to playing grandparents
and things like that
mmm it's tragic it's so hard to be a
white straight man in Hollywood an on
Scientology quite straight man in
Hollywood that's for certain but that
must have been such a thrill to be able
to be in this unbelievably successful
miniseries with your father and playing
the younger version of him very much
like what ice-cubes son got to do in the
film Straight Outta Compton yeah
although of course he was playing his
father outright yeah and also I mean he
I think he was he's a better actor than
I am it is the first thing oh that's not
serious Ben Dreyfus you were you were so
convincing as a younger Madoff I wanted
to strangle you through the screen I
mean the nice thing about it was you
know they they they my dad and after he
was doing it and then I had to beat an
audition against my brother really no I
mean not not really we but like there
wasn't a nationwide audition here it was
look like my father
right right right and my brother looks a
lot like him but not as much like him
and so we both like went in a net with
the director and then I am the one who
played it so haha Harry oh my good
Harry Dreyfus he must be livid I'm sure
he's doing somewhere he just taller than
me is the real problem it's worked out
for him in the rest of his life but now
he's just right all take that Harry
Dreyfus and so is acting the family
business I mean obviously you do a lot
of other things we've met many times I
do things on a pundit tree yeah as well
for politics obviously with your being
an editor at Mother Jones is acting the
first love that you had or what was it
was at politics or how did that no I
mean it
wanted to be an actor and I acting what
should have been the family business but
I just I I didn't become a famous actor
to my surprise people say that people
say that in Hollywood nepotism is a huge
thing right should be but the thing is
it's not enough
I left NYU and went to LA and was like
alright I'm ready to be a movie star
thank you I've been promised this I got
my college degree it tells me I'm a
journey in Muhtar god I literally have
to have totaled cars right I know
everything that we need to do I've done
drugs I've done all the things that we
need give me give me a Golden Globe
right and that didn't happen and so I
was shocked and I ended up having to
become a journalist because I needed
health insurance and to pay my rent what
a tragic tale Frazee forced into
journalism to bend Dreyfuss story really
I mean it is five years later and I'm
still I'm still still shockingly in
journalism yeah waiting gun to my head
gun to gun in the mouth bang it's it's a
but I mean hopefully hopefully one day
my dad will become famous again and I'll
be able to leave credit in this line I
can just go back to Los Angeles no but
uh well his younger made off role this
is gonna be this is the launching
imagine you're looking for like young
Madoff goes and solves crimes in the
1960s around he little vans with Scooby
and his buddies that's right that's
right
so you went you graduated from NYU with
the with the degree in acting I would
assume with like a with one of those
degrees where you sort of you know have
a lot of fingers in a lot of different
cups right right right
that's right so what are those college
degrees that nobody gets a job from
totally yeah Brown perfect yeah yes so
what was it like when you got to when
you got to LA you were really you were
expecting it success overnight when you
didn't find it what was how long did it
take you before you not that you gave up
on the actor dream but before you were
like maybe I'll try to dip my toe in
another field so when I ran out of money
oh that's it literally when it's really
when you get the call that's like
there's no more money in the bank again
oh my god but yeah I know there's cycles
of denial you know you start and you're
like I'll just go and it should be easy
and then a couple months later you're
like it hasn't happened yet and pilot
seasons going around maybe I'll become a
screenwriter
and then a couple of months go by and
then it's been two years maybe I'll be a
director maybe I'll be a PA maybe I'll
be maybe I'll just
you know go to Venice Beach juggle maybe
I'll just do something can I be a light
I can work in the lighting this will
sleep with you for money like there you
get to all these levels and then
eventually you do run out of money and
my sister at the time was working as an
actual journalist and had gone to
college for journalism and it worked her
way up from small-town paper to write
and then she took great pity on me and
they were hiring someone at cnet.com to
work on their social media and they
didn't really know what social media was
at the time and I had gotten into a
fight with Joe Scarborough on Twitter
and what was the fight with Joe
Scarborough for those that don't know
Joe Scarborough he was a Republican
senator very well-respected now he hosts
a great show on MSNBC called Morning Joe
I absolutely love it
of course I don't wake up that early in
the morning but occasionally I stay up
throughout the night and I catch you to
five a cup for Nia where it's on
incredibly early right but it was during
me was like in 2009 and he said
something about she said something about
how Americans were more conservative
than I thought they were mm-hm and I
called him a curse word that is a
British term for a vagina oh okay and
then he told me to kill myself in some
way on Twitter and Gawker ended up
writing about it and because of that my
sister was able to tell her colleagues
had seen it that uh her brother knows
Twitter really well Gawker's written
approvingly about his Twitter account
hilarious so the fight that you had on
Twitter with Joe Scarborough that's what
launched your journalism career yep
perfect that's amazing and of course the
English word for vagina apple crumble
yeah he called Joe Scarborough and apple
crumble not a lot of people know that's
what the British refer to the vagina as
it was a less problematic time back then
in 2009 or 10 right could just say
whatever you want it do you think with
the was the name Dreyfus at the end you
know Ben Dreyfus do you think that L
gave Joe the the desire to go and attack
you no I don't think he knew who I was I
think I think that he of course had no
idea who he was just and he also didn't
tell me to kill myself he told me like
take some pills and drink vodka with it
but it was like
that's actually just kind of fun
friendly advice to have a good night and
I was little did he know I was on pills
and vodka and I was like oh my god this
is weird
simpatico but no yeah so that that
that's what that that's how I got into
journalism really so it wasn't nepotism
from my dad it wasn't it wasn't for my
sister interesting yeah and was your
father approving of you getting into
acting as an actor himself obviously you
guys won't be competing for roles but he
knows the hardships of Hollywood and how
awful and fickle and you know how
shallow the industry is was he did he
ever give you advice on like get out get
out now never go in yeah I mean my dad a
hundred percent that is actually a quote
basically my dad had a really unique
experience in Hollywood because he my
dad's a great actor and he yeah he he he
didn't really have the time that people
have where they are struggling at it
mmm-hmm you know he grew up in Los
Angeles and was in on B which he was in
high school MMN like when Dan sent his
20s doing TV and he then won an Academy
Award at like 29 right and so he very
quickly like his he he was a prince of
all of it from a very young age and so
the entire notion of like it you're
you're not immediately getting it my dad
was like well I guess you know probably
not as good as I am as he's looking at
Oscar you don't have to constantly clean
it with your tongue like my mom my mom's
name is Jeremy rain and she had the
exact opposite experience in Hollywood
where she like isn't a very good actress
and she was in like you know b-list
movies in the seventies where you're
kidnapped and there's like sexploitation
oh then she was in like Wes Craven
movies where she's helping the people
kill the other people I guarantee you
I've seen more movies that your mother
was in your father I guarantee that's
true
I mean my mom is the sweetest person in
the entire world the best person with a
West Virginia draw ever to kill and rape
coeds in West in West Haven films but
she's also just not she had the exact
opposite experience and so my mom was
the person in the family who was like
you kids think you're gonna go and just
become movie stars not like that you're
gonna turn out she was a hundred percent
right and as she was saying that you're
like don't know I have dreams mom you
know I do what are you talking about
obviously I'll be in Mission Impossible
3 right what are you saying
absolute
so I mean it's funny because my father
is a not a very he's not a successful
guy he's an immigrant from Germany he's
a truck driver and in my entire life I'm
like hey not exactly gonna be difficult
to outdo what he did with his life
unless of course we measure success in
life by how many highway miles one has
clocked but for you having that having
the father you know sort of be this an
icon to some degree how does that feel
as a son are you constantly trying to
outdo him are you proud of him because
for me I have a little bit of I'm a
little bit upset with my father for not
going out there and becoming something a
little bit bigger and better but you
have a father who actually went out
there and excelled what's it like
growing up under that shadow I mean I
I mean I'm immensely proud of my dad
yeah and I I've never I've never known a
moment in my life when I haven't really
been been aware of how great he is on it
at the stupid thing that he does for a
career right and also just who he is and
all the other things but I also I
totally understand about that like very
few moments in my life have I ever been
like I will surpass my father in some
regard right and you know they only
normally happen when you're a teen and
you're you're you know you're in some
state of mania and you're like oh win
that Academy Award at 28 that's not
exactly how it happens right but I do
think that like I think that you know
fathers and sons no matter how no matter
how it works always really complicated
like whether whether they're famous or
not mm-hmm people always used to ask us
like what's it like having you know the
famous father and the answer is like I
don't really have anything to compare it
to right but I think that like I think
that no matter what no matter what
you're gonna have a complicated
relationship with your father
yeah absolutely I don't know one person
without a complicated relationship with
their father they don't have a unless
they don't have one and then that's a
whole nother complicated relationship
with their father's ghost in a scarecrow
and just being like want to play a game
of catch like yeah exactly
so now you're working for Mother Jones I
mean this political I do a great
political show I can't wait to have you
wanted it's called Abe Lincoln's top hat
on KF comedy radio if you haven't heard
it please go out there and give it a
listen it's phenomenal and Ben Dreyfus
will be on I'm just
Keenum right now he will be on in the
future in the near future politics
you've been following the Democratic
primary very closely obviously Mother
Jones is a little bit more of a
left-leaning I guess it's a blog is that
what things were technicals we're a
magazine I'm a go print magazine okay I
don't I'm more on the website but yeah
we're a print circulation magazine I
mean what a hell of a past year it's
been huh when it comes to the Democratic
primary I mean this is the most exciting
time for a political journalist without
a doubt don't you think totally I mean
absolutely I think that like especially
at this exact moment right before the
New Hampshire primary where you have
this you know Hillary just won Iowa book
by like a you know a tiny little by an
apple crumbles hair by six point flips
yeah I think that you really want it by
more than a couple coin flips as like
they do bunk that MSNBC Bing about that
I think but yeah even then regardless
you know pretty tiny very very small
very small and you have Bernie Sanders
who a lot of people feel very passionate
about but then a lot of other people
feel you know is living in a world of
pure imagination and you know is doesn't
necessarily have and so I don't go
putting Willy Wonka songs in my head by
the way
imagination that's he's in a wonkavator
just waiting day he does but so I think
it's a really interesting time for the
Democrats I am fonder of Hillary I think
yes I think that like well because you
think she's more reasonable yeah I'm
what she her lower expectations are
possible to achieve yeah I mean she has
realistic goals right and I think that
also she's I personally find her more
likable to be honest you know I know
that there's been along things over the
years of people not liking Hillary I
find Hillary pretty likable I think that
Bernie Sanders maybe too much reminds me
of all the uncles that I know who are
old Jewish men barking at me my bar
mitzvah is right right need I don't know
there's a little there's an anger that I
find sort of unappealing well I think
your father could play Bernie Sanders in
a TV movie and you could play young
Bernie Sanders in a TV movie and you'll
just have an entire career playing young
bird Weber Sanders Sanders how do you
proud to get that bed Dreyfus kid I
think that I mean yeah we'll just we'll
get a lot of I'll play the young version
of old Jewish man Oh perfect
that'll be that that's an amazing career
that you're gonna believe it or not
there's a lot of old Jewish men who have
a lot of acting work and I'm sure that
they've got a younger version of
themselves but I mean I think that like
for all the funds and games of like the
Democratic race which really like for
regardless of like how close this
election is right now right the funnels
haven't changed Hillary's probably then
you have the Republican side which has
had the most you know surprising gear no
one could have guessed exactly how this
would have turned out raikou everyone
thought you know Jeb Bush was gonna be
was gonna be like no even if not
everyone be like there was a general
understanding he would probably be one
of the people ended up and now we have
yeah Donald Trump and Ted Cruz and Marco
Rubio who and like Rubio I guess people
always respected well speaking of legacy
is we've been discussing no one has a
more powerful family than Jeb Bush
obviously he is failing miserably in the
polls so miserably he is forcing his 90
year old mother out with her Walker to
New Hampshire she's walking through snow
banks walking in snowstorms having to
hang out with people she doesn't want to
associate with and Buzard
diners and delis all across New
Hampshire do you have any sympathy for
Jeb Bush a hundred percent and how bad
of a can mother and for his poor poor
mother who's very old and being trotted
out like a prop in all of these things
and the father of all the bushes I have
sympathy for all the bushes here yeah I
mean you have to right because I mean
you you don't have no one thought that
we ever would have sympathy for Jeb but
he's just done so bad it's almost to the
point that he's a special-needs child
he's added in people to clap for him
he's asking people to clap for him
what's been some of your favorite
experience is working for Mother Jones
has there been a politician or a public
figure that you had an opportunity to
meet that you're just really proud of
your life decision to get rid of acting
a bunch of losers and Schmucks and move
over to journalism no I mean I I'm I'm
not a reporter so I don't going out into
the field and meet I I haven't I think
since working at Mother Jones met any
politicians except for others I bet have
been prior in my life because they like
to come out to Hollywood right no I
think that I've loved about working at
by the judges that you get actually
write about politics and do these things
that matter and you know
part of in some small sense the like
important discussions in our country
about gun violence dissolution all of
these things even if even if it's only
that my contribution to that is is you
know collaterally right but III
definitely before that I worked at this
place called C net where I would write
about cell phones and so it was a nice
things it's a nice write a nice move
from writing about the Samsung Galaxy
three to writing about gun violence yeah
I suppose so yeah I think cell phones
aggravate me more don't a strange way
look I mean like gun violence might have
blood on its hands but cell phones are
the thing you spend your day cursing at
exactly the gun violence has blood on
your hands but phones have blood coming
out of your ears
it's terrible these things we're all
gonna get brain cancer I'm sure of it
but at the same time and I mean I got to
use it I mean if it doesn't get brain
cancer we're all gonna if they're giving
you brain cancer which I don't think
they are we're all getting brain cancer
together that's right
so of course Mother Jones the the head
of Mother Jones are more than one of the
more powerful figures he's regularly on
the MSNBC show hardball with Chris
Matthews Chris Matthews has a lot of
spit has got a lot of spit coming out of
his mouth on a regular basis but the
guest for Mother Jones is David corn
yeah David is the DC bureau chief
he's the DC bureau chief and what do you
think about this guy because sometimes I
see him on screen and I say just like
that little young Bernie Madoff I want
to strangle him I mean David David
fantastic David's a fantastic DC you
know he's on the pulse of it and he's
you know the forty seven percent video
David is always he the one who broke the
forty seven percent video those that
don't remember Mitt Romney was given a
private speech at a dinner full of very
wealthy people one of the bartenders or
waiters secretly filmed him probably
with the samsung galaxy wasn't iPhone
quality no it was not iPhone quality
Mitt Romney admitted that 47% of the
general electorate won't be voting for
him and this got blown into a very large
scandal for the Romney campaign they've
really never recovered and a lot of
people give that as one of the main
reasons he lost the race other than the
fact he was a very white bread person
who never had any problems in his life
yeah you know but yes I think that I
think that you know it was on the
newsroom season two if you've seen the
newsroom season 2 there's a whole
there's episode about it uh uh um but
yeah no I think the David is wonderful
they wonderful of ideal of what you have
is a DC journalist and you know how you
can be inside the beltway and also do
investigative work and not you know
become beholden to the sort of Politico
sort of nonsense that people have about
like rewriting press releases from the
government of the Interior yeah yeah
yeah yeah so did you grow up just
switching a little bit now because I
mean I'm I am from Wisconsin originally
are you cheese state that JD oh my god
there's so much cheese Wisconsin it's
full of cheese chalets which is a cheese
shop Calais Shelley not shallots butter
a lot of tiny that's a very fancy yes
that's right but you put the word cheese
in front of anything and you know I'm
sold it makes it slightly less classy
you know but that's okay the cheese
what's a classy word chief right for
anything what's a classy word beignet
she's been yeah well that actually stops
very good never mind scratch my theory
and solo that was a great that was a
great one beignet it always sounded like
the fanciest sounding donut donut with
the fancy way with the oh you and
everything and then you have been yet
well I am livid now that I think about
it I'm livid there isn't somebody who
owns a donut store who has a doughnut
called the JonBenet Ramsay don't the
JonBenet Ramsey doughnut too soon it's
only been 20 years or something I love
it yeah I mean also they never found her
maybe she's working in a shop called the
John I they found her down there she was
he defined her they found her they found
that there's they never found anything
they still didn't have any idea what
happened for if you want more
information on I do a podcast on the
last podcast on the left we do a we did
a full two-parter on Jon Benet it's
fascinating the story itself is
incredible go back on KF comedy radio
and give that a listen anyway where you
from where did your parents raise you um
I was born in Los Angeles and okay then
did you go to one of those Oh in Idaho
yeah and Sam died too
when did you move to Idaho in the early
90s and like 92 93 so you were a young
man a young man 7 8 9 10
yeah what why did they choose to move
rope in home
oh I said divorce happened and then you
end up moving to Sun Valley Idaho it's
what happens so did you go to live with
the mom or you go to live with the dead
I'm assuming the mother because mr.
Dreyfus probably wants to stay in LA
yeah no I'm live with my mom in Sun
Valley because my father had to say and
you know Los Angeles to work right and
so then I got to grow up in the one
little the one County in Idaho where
people are all from Los Angeles or
Seattle or New York and all my resort
it's the only place where Jews are
really allowed night out oh isn't that
nice yeah isn't that wonderful
so you went to the potato steak yeah you
left beautiful Los Angeles which which
is full of well I suppose and then in
the 90s the food wasn't supposed to but
it wasn't that good nowadays la food is
phenomenal it was pretty good in the 90s
it was pretty good like Idaho is a lot
of great qualities it's the most
beautiful state you'll ever see the
Pacific Northwest it's you know stunning
God came down mom's thank perfect God
God came down a man Idaho yeah on the
sixth day no it the fifth day I don't
know what they did
yeah whatever the days oh-hoh and he
came down he made Idaho and it was
beautiful and then he rested and then a
bunch of like Idaho was also filled with
a lot of you know it's culturally
southern and there's a lot of blood
Ariane's up north and the potatoes down
south and the meth in Caldwell and all
over they talk about the Aryan race meth
and potatoes and potato but it's also no
matter what they're the nicest people
it's a really it's very nice state and
it's also this most stunning it's a
really beautiful postcard safe oh yeah
you know I Love Lucy once there's a lot
of noise right so what the hell happened
your mom woke you up when when one day
and was like we're getting a divorce and
we're moving to Idaho we had we they had
a it they had a home we'd like on to
Christmas in Idaho and then one day do
you think they were preparing you
they're like we'll get divorced in four
years but I don't think they all
together they're like look we're gonna
where should we go let's let's look at
tax retreats alright Idaho is the place
to go because then you go to a blizzard
no sales tax no I think the rise that
there was the
when my mom and dad decided to get
divorce my mom was like well where do we
go I don't know what's look like I guess
we'll go to Idaho and that's how we
ended up there and it's a very nice
place to grow up because you can you
know don't have to lock your doors and
right although then we spent a lot of
time there and then until we were all me
and my siblings were like in teen
teenagers and we decided to rebel and
wanted to go live with dad and in like
the big city right right right
with that that's a hell of an option to
have yeah it's really nice no I mean
absolutely we were blessed to have to be
able to have that there's also nice too
when you have a when you're from
divorced parents to be able to say to
the other one I'm leaving and going to
live with dad oh my god because I think
if I had actually called my dad and said
that he would have been like that's not
how it works
I am busy I can't I don't have another
room for you but just the threat really
gets the Christmas gifts from the mom to
be a lot better yeah so I'm when you're
an Idaho your dad's in LA but was he
able to have contact there's there's
airplanes there are airplanes this
wasn't this wasn't the 20s when it was
like all right I'll see you later kid
I'll see you in four days on the Union
Pacific I do kind of think of all
divorces go in that way especially when
the families separate at some point you
know a mother is with her three children
on a coal train just slice sadly passing
through stop because just dad just looks
way inches up well thank God a new
family yeah yeah thank god that's done
finally I got rid of him no I mean know
that like you know wheat this was the
this was the 90s 18th Ma Bell had come
back together yeah he'd already fixed
all the phone things I even had
cellphones and also I remember he used
to have us back in the old days of like
58 point k8k modems we would have video
chats that didn't move a lot but like
you'd have like a little photo that
moved they were installed people coming
it's all a [ __ ] camera in our house
yeah and this is way ahead of its time
yeah yeah no way we didn't work very
well but now I was still playing Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles on my Mac and every
time you would go down the sewer tunnel
it took 15 minutes to load the next
scene it was a nightmare
and you got you got video I remember I
remember that game and that level and I
know exactly what you're talking about
I'm still upset about it I ad I'm livid
with the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
game for anyone who is of our generation
will totally understand
there were real consequences when you
made a mistake in old video games it
would just start you over from the
beginning or you would take 15 minutes
to load as they show you you know the
mistake level between fellow games that
I used to play as a child that I still
have never beaten like I I spent my
childhood trying to beat Zelda and
certain things but like no that just I
don't even know I probably didn't even
get past the first couple levels because
they were impossible very difficult they
were totally impossible they were never
made for people in adult if you gave me
a lot of adderall and you know just a
couple of weeks off I could probably do
it now but I feel like that would be a
weird way to spend my adderall or my
vacation no you're an adult male yeah
please don't do that if you're gonna
take a bunch of adderall you do
something constructive yeah just go I
don't even get it
go do a bunch of auditions really fast I
don't know what the hell you'll do so
when you were growing up and I know did
people know you were the son of Richard
Dreyfuss small towns word spreads quick
and I would assume did was there ever
attention or just like celebrity boys
here or what was because a lot of time
kids are terrible yeah there was and
it's like we grew up in a time with like
other other it's one of those towns
where there was you know the Willises
lived there and we grew up with Oh like
Bruce Willis and and sort of like there
was there it wasn't as crazy as you
might think right but also like it there
was there's natural thing of us being
you know we were wearing leather jackets
and jib from LA and also I have one I
know I sort of was like this weird
person who couldn't play soccer and go
skiing with all of them but was wearing
a leather jacket and like telling weird
stories about Los Angeles and sort of
being not you know it must have helped
with the ladies oh yeah yeah definitely
it's having when I was great
well not the one I think is it are you
blind in one eye yours at a glass eye
well I mean it's both its glass and I
can't see out of it well can imagine
though soon it'll be glass and you will
be able to see how absolutely but the
thing I really recall like when we first
moved to when we first moved to Idaho
they sent a an optometrist to our school
and like we had these preconceived
notions about what Idaho is like yeah
you know because you such as it sits
back yes you know and the parameters
comes up to me and is does the test he
says all right put your right eye in the
thing he doesn't sound like
at all but I'm gonna use that action
anyway sure zoom yeah look at the right
thing and I go AV qlt 17 News all right
all right what do you see to your left
eye and I was like sir I don't know and
he was like just tell me what you see
and I was like God else I just made some
stuff up yeah and then we got this card
from him this is like our first week in
Idaho and it said he's 2020 in his right
eye and 2050 in his left eye
and my mom was like you don't even have
a left eye it's made of glass I think
that uh Tom at wrist was drunk I'm just
gonna say well so you go to when Tyra
they didn't even have the optometrist
literally couldn't even at the most
basic level right your glass eye sees
better than most people actually a glass
eye is legally allowed to drive in most
states
oh my god that's hilarious what it was a
it was a born condition and I lose it
throughout life I mean I used to lie and
tell people I lost it and like a knife
fight but that's a good way to do it it
is I mean if you're gonna also if you as
long as you're on the right side of the
knife fight you don't want to lose it if
like you're mugging someone right right
that's just embarrassing
then you're not only a bad mugger but
you're a mugger that's right want to lie
and say you were defending someone from
being mugged of course but now I love I
was born with this thing called Peters
anomaly did a it looked great was born
wrong and broken
so there's popped it out out and put it
in the glass he popped it out after a
little bit because it didn't look right
and I was like oh Jesus stop what a hell
of a surgeon that sounds got a nightmare
surgery yeah no I mean I think I was out
for it thank God it yeah it would be
terrible if you weren't out yeah what
else would they yeah they got it you got
to get knocked out yeah I'm not just
gonna give you enough Demerol where they
can just spoon out your eye yeah that's
it sort of like I feel like that's a
Vietnam film we probably happen to the
Nam film I'm sure it happened a lot in
Vietnam in real life as I'm sure it
happened in Vietnam is a great thing to
always say to people oh yeah you think
you're special it used to happen in Nam
quite a lot exactly it probably happened
some of those West Craven films your
mother started she was constantly
spooning people's eyes out always just
right and left yeah is that something I
mean obviously I'm sure people bring it
up is it something you're really
sensitive about or were you is growing
up I mean every oh is it you know being
six foot seven for me I was very fat as
well you know these are always things
everyone's always pointing out the most
obvious flaw you're like I got it I know
all about it I'm living inside of it I
hate every second want to talk about my
parents divorce to like what
get into that please god no I mean I do
think that yeah like you definitely have
a bunch of like weird stuff about it
about when you're growing up if you ever
do that you got to pop it out sometimes
in class well my parents were divorced
my mom had like boyfriends and I would
be like if I want to get rid of this
boyfriend I'm gonna take my idiot bunch
of are used to pop it out without
touching it like I could just have my
eyes looking out and so that is a great
way to terrify someone who's dating your
mother oh yeah but you know you're gonna
be a great grandfather oh you're gonna
have the best grandfather trick ever and
the kids are just gonna be terrified but
they're gonna constantly request that
you do okay I don't even remember your
names who are you oh they love it yeah
you all have it roll around on the
ground a little bit around Pat Minnie
would you just give it to them let them
play with the I they'll just ya know
yeah I think that everyone I mean
whether you're six foot seven and fat or
one-eyed and five foot seven it doesn't
matter there's right be something where
you're like oh my god
that's why you got a well done for those
you know moderately height weighted to
I'd people there right God's children
but then they complain about not having
any problems I know they complain about
being like a single child or a child
there's a lie I know people who are only
children who are like oh you don't know
what it's like so difficult being the
only time having everything that you
ever wanted with no one fighting for
know you're like oh god it sounds so
difficult it sounds so hard the
privilege yeah exactly the privilege of
not having your toys destroyed on a
regular basis by an aggressive older
sibling yeah what are you the oldest the
youngest middle I'm the middle list and
I'm the I have an elder sister and a
younger brother okay that's cool and you
guys yeah and of course now your younger
brother he is obviously attempting to
act as well he's I mean he's in LA as a
Harry he's in Los Angeles he's like 25
and tall and blond and he's a he's doing
what you do in Hollywood an actor and a
writer and a director and yeah all those
fun things it seems like the whole
family is absolutely crushing it and
finding their own way in life which is
amazing I mean we I mean finally good
eventually you have to after years of us
out in the wilderness seems like we
finally
oh yeah I know it's nice it's all it's
all it's been it's good I mean we've
been very lucky and had a lot of
opportunities now so 12 years old you
went was it 12 or 13 or 14 when you went
back to LA I don't know around there
around preteen so you're like as soon as
high school hit you're like I am getting
out of here a little bit later I went
then moved to New York and like did all
i saw the movie kids and was like this
know what I want I want it I want to do
that thing that rosario Dawson was doing
in that movie yeah yeah so then I moved
to the big city and yeah favorite city
LA or New York or Idaho
I mean it's far state not Idaho I mean I
live in New York and I Love New York I
love it because I don't have to drive
really yeah and I'm a terrible driver
I've destroyed a lot of cars how many
cars you got under under the belt I have
totaled two cars not bad I totaled two
as well what type of cars did you total
alright so my first car ever was a Ford
Thunderbird and I loved very cool it was
and I started drinking at the age of 12
and I didn't stop you know it's
Wisconsin where I'm from so you know be
knowing what Idaho is like it's very
similar except for instead of potatoes
again we have cheese and horn shops
that's all Wisconsin has this toy shop
horn chops because Wisconsin much like
Idaho it's just a trucker drive
yesterday so truckers are apparently
just jerking off constantly craving
cheese I don't know those those cabins
of the trucks must smell something
atrocious worst in the tombs it's very
sticky yeah sticky and oh but the guy is
always full of cheese so I guess good
for him
so I had a Thunderbird and sure enough
I'm driving to school one day and I I
just crossed the street like an idiot
and a car t-bones me this guy is very
upset because he lost his favorite car
of all time
meanwhile the trunk of my car pops open
beer cans just go flying full beer I
wasn't drunk I mean this was in the
morning that was yeah and I would assume
I was going to consume those beers later
that night so that was my first accident
and you know it was it was fairly
shocking and then I had a yellow Geo
Metro and there was a parking lot
situation I was literally longer than
this car it was a convertible
somebody hit me in a parking lot and the
car pretty much exploded and I think the
collision was at five miles an hour was
it your fault
every accident was my phone I got three
cars another time I was driving this
huge Oldsmobile I have no idea where the
hell I got it I think I bought about
five hundred bucks and I just rear-ended
somebody on a highway so I totaled three
cars I mean I I drove I I flipped a Jeep
once not bad and into a tree and I sober
or drunk or is this awful I'm not gonna
I'm not named to that question we got a
real Martin shkreli over here he's
pleading the fifth I'm not I know trey
gowdy my friend he also killed a deer
once it destroyed a car but then also I
would assume the deer that that had to
be an idle deers fault too of course for
those that don't know the middle of the
country these deers are menace and they
also teach you when you're getting your
license to hit it
they also say like don't try and not hit
it cuz you'll end up flipping your car
and going like hitting the tree in front
just keep going
take that deer dad that deer asked for
it and then I also went to visit my
brother once when he was at acting camp
in upstate New York and we had a rental
car or rental Buick
drove accidentally off of a cliff
because it was raining and the hell did
you survive that I mean I have no idea
but I do know how high was the cliff
high enough that the car was destroyed
the Buick was destroyed the Buick was
thank God American Express had had
insurance that are you sure you're not
like living the life of a Hollywood
actor living the life of a character in
a Hollywood film and very rarely do
people survive cars with wine off a
cliff so I did survive it and I went to
see Harry in the play and he was the
thing and I I had hit my head and was
sort of like passing out
oh my play and my mom was there and had
to get up and leave the play to go like
deal with the fact that we were now in
the middle of nowhere and my brother
tells the story of playing some you know
Greek character and seeing me falling
asleep on the on the ground and my
mother running around to go get like an
ambulance oh my god thing turned out
great the worst heckle ever your brother
your brother has died for a moment from
a concussion and I would he was like god
you're destroying my play as well right
he must have been so pissed my older
brother's taking all the attention again
I he didn't even die it would have been
one thing if I had died in the thing
yeah you tell that story
oh that's better accidents than mine
were just I was
I don't know what it was until I was
around until I was about 22 I just I
just didn't look I just wasn't looking
anywhere it's really not do be a good
driver
yeah easy to just go exactly just do it
alone like oh these stop signs aren't
for me yeah everybody else stops except
for me I'm gonna be fine through not a
problem I'm the one driver with a plan
I'm just gonna roll through it and which
is really what we've brought to life
which i think is an asset at some point
just roll through no matter what the
hell happens just keep on rolling
through until the day you don't
and then then it'll be they'll just
they'll say other they'll say nice
things at the funeral yeah then you got
a little eulogy and everyone's just like
no and it was like you know what I mean
they're just there for the meat plate
probably for the open casket so they can
mock your face but you can't react you
yell at them I mean that's a that's
that's the lowest hanging fruit to make
fun of people in a casket I love it what
would you do open casket closed casket
been dreyfuses funeral in the Year 2075
I want an open casket and I would also
want to be like in an above-ground
mausoleum type of things I don't want
the worms to come after me and all of
that really so you would prefer the
small almost I guess a Chinese hotel
type situation fantastic just a drawer
in just a nice little like above-ground
drawer up in some nice above-ground
Mazal and you want I suppose you would
have to be frozen then at that point is
that how they do alive enough to freeze
me I think there's no reason not to like
I think they can look I don't know how
far medical science has gotten but if I
have enough assets to pay for that which
I probably don't in this scenario
like to just do their best try try and
keep me alive as long as possible yeah
who would you like to see it your
funeral oh I would like the people at my
funeral to be none of my enemies I'd
like all of my enemies to be dead every
oh you want the enemies yeah I mean
everyone at the funeral should be people
who I always thought the like you know
if you've been a very good person when
you die the last thing you hear is that
like you know everyone who loves you and
everyone you love will be okay and
they'll get through it right if you've
been a very bad person when you die the
last thing you hear is all of your
enemies are gonna be okay
yeah you're gonna be happy they'll get
through it do you have any main enemies
not that I'm gonna mention you have to
mention one no I've never
Sandhya's because I'll help their Google
search results I don't oh I see of
course we have enemies enemies are fun
sort of motivate you to get up every day
and work hard are your enemies in the
entertainment sector or in the political
sector I don't really have any enemies
in the political sector other than like
ideological disagreements right with
people like Joe Scarborough
who even he seems like a nice person
yeah no actually I would like you know
it so you always have anything personal
based you know yet mrs. personal base
because they went to the prom with Jenny
or something like that
who are your nemesis is man you know is
nemesis no which is a great speaking of
video games as we were previously
resident evil nemesis is a is a great
game I'm trying to think I know I have a
few from high school people that I can
go back one's name was Casey and I mean
a true the I think I've discussed it on
this show previously there's a little
cliche that all of your bullies in high
school will just stay in your hometown
and become janitors or drunks yeah and
or both
drunken janitors which is really cool
yeah good Anya if you're a janitor
please just be drunk and I love
everything that you're doing
his name was Casey there's another guy
named Dan and I'm trying to think Jason
maybe a Jason either way why no no this
is this is what Stevens Point Wisconsin
there's no big city Idaho my friend no
and back to Brussels I'm sorry those
that that like group of people they used
to do this thing it was called the dime
drill and they did it to all the
freshmen or not all the freshmen I mean
I have to get older brothers and they
both left when I was a freshman in high
school so I got a lot of the brunt of
the homophobic attacks even though I'm
straight so I have you know and I and I
can't even go to the LGBT communities
and tell them how tortured I was I don't
care
LGBT like al-anon so there was a thing
we had to push a dime around a toilet
bowl I mean it was a terrible experience
and there was a lot of bullying going on
so those guys those are my enemies and
that you know I see them on Facebook and
I just revel in their misery you know
the best photos they have or then the
their greatest accomplishments are
killing a 30-point buck you know or
killing some random animal usually with
their
trash car so those are my enemies but
you're right it is tough I don't have
any I don't have any career enemies
there are some people who have taken who
have gotten roles over me when it comes
to talking head thingy not talking head
things or very small things there was
something I was doing for a internet
company that used to be extremely famous
which is now - Yahoo isn't it it's close
but not quite and they gave the job to
this real prick and he's a total schmuck
and you know sure enough that project
completely fell apart and now I'm all
over Fox News so I take great you know
always a much rather be on Fox News the
number one cable network then some you
know dead internet channel so I take I
do take some solace in that but I think
that you make it that you're right anger
it can feed you but especially in this
business you can't let it a heart attack
you know I mean I was like the closest I
ever came to be being there was like a
number of times in movies where I'd be
like you know almost the it's between me
and someone else and that other person
gets it and right would get to be in the
stupid movie about mutants and yeah
exactly
the thing is I have no I they say this
thing in a a we know like look if you
can drink normally we tip your hats to
them and like I don't tip my I don't tip
my hats to those don't even own a hat
you son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah um but I do
get like you know like well done you got
you get to play that role and now you're
famous and I jealous of you a thousand
times but I'm also you know look I'm not
gonna keep your car very good I'm not
gonna keep your car sir I'm not gonna
key it okay right right right
um but ya know I think it like
especially when you're talking about
like high school enemies you have all of
these things where you get to looking
like they've all aged so poorly it's
really nice yeah see how poorly people
have aged and it's also fun to like I'll
say the few people on the internet who I
have been terrible to I mean there's a
lot of limit but like that's big desert
Durban - I felt bad for being mean to
somebody then you met them in real life
you're actually a nice person no no no
no so when you have the rage when you
have the dreyfus rage and you know for a
fact that it's well-placed people who
act differently on the internet than
they do a normal in normal life and I've
always been really proud of like my
internet personality being being a very
honest trailer for the live show of bed
drivers right right actually what you're
gonna get and like so I mean I'm sort of
a prick on the internet notice but I'm
also
sort of a prick in real life sometimes
but I think that like one of the things
that I have been to people I have never
never
nothing great too is like my name is Ben
Dreyfus um whenever there's been Twitter
I've always had like at Ben Dreyfus
right and I've always liked reserved
those the second I can and there's a few
other Ben dreyfuses in the world that I
know about from like Google okay and
they like one used to play tennis at
Brandeis and like whenever I've gotten
like Gmail at Ben Dreyfus I've been like
always like email at Ben drivers number
one like haha idiot I got it I got it
like I didn't I was like I got it I got
at been driving us this time do they
even care
one time one of them Rebecca Peters like
shut up and I was like all right
but then snapchat is a really big to do
like for over the years because I just
kept always getting it like it's like
three of them right but then one of them
got snapchat Ben Dreyfus and so I had a
vision and I started to like snap at
them like to shame and the Ben drivers
as far as when you google Ben Dreyfus is
yours the first name to come up yeah
okay good Ben Kissel is also the first I
mean the only Ben Kissel all according
to Google which I really like cos
Carelli when you google your name yeah
there are you the only mic cos Carelli
you come out actually you guys I come up
first but I'm not the there's some kid
in Michigan who was like a baseball
player does he have does he have Twitter
or does he have like just yeah but he's
a total [ __ ] [ __ ] well you gotta
take them down you gotta do it your but
you still you obviously with the young
man off stuff are you are you excited ah
oh my god I can drive this disease mad
off which is actually more difficult to
say that yeah but you're gonna keep on
acting yeah I mean I'll do anything for
money right I mean I feel like and I
feel like you would make a perfect
villain for some reason is just because
the Ben Dreyfus Twitter Halloween that's
nothing that yeah I mean that's I'm
golden villain for that yeah no I mean
yeah absolutely I I think I'll probably
keep acting and tight in and out and
like doing other side of journalism is
there any dream role is there any is
there any character that I guess is sort
of in the
in the lexicon now that you would just
love to play I don't know about that a
Bond villain or maybe James Bond himself
you know no I don't think they have a
lot of Jewish American bonds yeah our
people who struggle for so long 5000
years we've been waiting to be a Bond
villain I mean I don't think there's
necessarily a specific role but I think
that I don't know there's there's a lot
of roles for poor Jewish American white
management yes there are I'll be fine
it's gonna be exciting man thank you so
much for being here
of course thank you for having me I know
I'm always shooting questions out
everyone just like stop asking me things
you were wonderful
no worries obviously we were discussing
Twitter you can find Ben Dreyfuss on
Twitter at and Dreyfuss not been
Dreyfuss one not been Dreyfuss 42069 at
Ben Dreyfuss he owns it and read his
articles on Mother Jones
it is really phenomenal he's an
extremely you are an extremely smart man
and as this political season continues
on if you are somebody who is
left-leaning you're gonna love being fed
everything that you want to hear and if
you're someone who is right leaning go
check out Mother Jones here with the
other size has to other side has to say
and and get a more informed opinion it's
a great great magazine all right Mike
coscarelli you can find Mike on Twitter
at Mike cast Carelli it's Mike unit not
my Casabella now is that Mike I am the
only at Mike Oscar le on Twitter
good I don't know if this other kid is
from Michigan he's got a die that's very
true
and of course check out Mike's podcast
social villains you will love it all
right I'm on Twitter at Ben Kissel make
sure to check out all my other shows on
cave comedy radio for politics check out
Abe Lincoln's top hat I cannot wait to
have been on and we will just talk about
politics for a full hour and it'll be
phenomenal and abling it stopped at
a roundtable of gentlemen and of course
the last podcast on the left and you can
also find me on twitter at been Kissel
alright everyone thanks for listening
and we'll talk to you soon it's for
listening we'll talk to you soon
it's for listen and we'll talk to you
soon it's for listening and we'll talk
to you soon it's for listening and we'll
talk to you soon
it's for listening we'll talk